pourquoi vous suivez claude françois de
tourner en tournée est ce qu'on les aime
bien vous c'est la même raison qui vous
pousse à quitter paris et faire du stop
pour venir à amiens voir claude françois
oui et vous moi c'est pareil et toutes
les semaines vous faites ça est ce que
vous pensez qu'il ya un mythe claude
françois sans doute
enfin je suppose je m'en rends pas
compte de la part des filles sûrement
oui
[Musique]
non
public c'est comme un chien qui sont
dans un couloir il est là il est prêt au
pire au meilleur
si vous arrivez avec des muscles d'un
pas décidé il a peur de vous si vous
arrivez légèrement flageolant et vous
moeurs et sincèrement pourquoi je ne
prends pas le but vide à un chien seul
angle négatif des choses au contraire je
compare lui qu'un chat sous l'angle
instinctif de la chose il est pour ou
contre
[Applaudissements]
et vous êtes allé jusqu'au bout comme ça
jusqu'à nice en stop oui vous êtes parti
combien de jours à jour le soir du gala
est pour part on vous laisse partir bien
sûr pourquoi vous aimez claude françois
est ce qu'il en ya est-ce qui vous voyez
vous a remarqué jeudi quelque chose
qu'est ce qui vous a dit vous êtes
amoureuse de lui
non qu'est ce que vous pensez des filles
qui vous accompagne à chaque gala des
finissants qui suivent toujours cc comme
c'est comme le fromage on aime bien le
matin peut-être un peu moins deux soirs
ça dépend enfin disons que je m'en
contente idéalement que j'en suis
positivement heureux et puis que
d'autres fois je m'ennuie profondément
[Musique]
je vais rentrer dans les secrets je ne
bois pas d'alcool du tout par contre je
vois un peu de whisky avant d'entrer sur
scène pour être un peu vivre un peu
déséquilibré par rapport à mon équilibre
jésuites presque de la situation
[Musique]
oh
combien de personnes dans votre équipe
j'en ai 27 dire 27 27 personnes sur
scène il y en a à peu près je connais 19
très exactement et puis tous les autres
tournent autour y à peu près donc huit
personnes qui tournent autour qui sont
très importantes également qu'on ne voit
pas les techniciens les chats vendus
sont les épées raciste
les hommes à la poursuite tout ça
[Musique]